SRINI DEVADAS: So, so
far we haven't really
done much with the
data structures
outside of Python lists.
We looked at two
dimensional lists
but, you know, they
are still lists.
And so this particular
puzzle that we're
going to do today, I--
has a graph structure
associated with it.
So for the first time,
at least in this class,
we'll be looking at
traversing graphs,
and we're going to do
this in a recursive way.
And, also, we'll have
a graph representation
using dictionaries.
So most of you have
probably seen dictionaries.
If you haven't, I'm
going to explain them.
They're essentially
ways that you
can index into
lists, not just using
nonzero integers, indices, zero
through n, or what have you.
But things like
strings or tuples,
and so they're just more general
and-- they're more general data
structure than Python lists.
And so they're very
convenient when
it comes to representing
graphs and traversing graphs.
So the puzzle we can
look at is, as always,
is a little bit contrived.
It's about weekend
dinner scheduling.
So you have a bunch of friends.
And let me draw your
social network here,
or someone's social network.
So we won't name names,
but each node in this graph
represents a friend,
and a couple more.
And so that's the set
of friends, a through h,
and that won't be particularly
interesting as a graph.
If it just had nodes,
you want to add edges
to it, what do these
edges represent?
Well, you like all
of your friends,
but your friends don't
necessarily like each other.
And so an edge between nodes--
so nodes are friends, and an
edge between a pair of nodes
implies a dislike relationship.
All right.
So b dislikes c,
and it's symmetric.
I mean, you could argue
that dislikes is not
necessarily symmetric, but
we'll just call it that.
That implies that c
dislikes b as well.
So this is not necessarily
a directed graph.
Some of the time,
especially when
you're doing group planning,
going from point A to point B,
you have to take into
account one-way streets,
and so you have directed graphs.
But many a time, you can get
away with undirected graphs.
So you just-- the existence
of an edge between B and C
implies that in a traversal, you
can get from B to C or C to B,
and there's no direction there.
And so I'm going to fill
in the rest of this,
and then get to the question
that we want to answer.
And so that's your--
your friend graph.
And it also has these six or
seven dislike relationships.
And your job is to, well,
keep all your friends happy.
And the way you're
going to do that is by--
is by having a couple of
parties on the weekend.
So this is a regular weekend.
Let's call it Friday
and Saturday--
Friday and Saturday
night parties.
And the only constraint--
actually, there's
two constraints.
There's-- the two constraints
that you need to follow are
satisfy when you have
these two parties.
So you have your Friday party
and your Saturday party,
is you can't leave
anybody out, right?
So you-- effectively, they're
constrained as each friend--
--comes to--
--exactly one party.
No one gets left out,
no one comes to both.
So that's fair.
And then the second constraint
as you can probably guess
is no pair--
--of friends who
dislike each other,
they're not friendly,
they're your friends,
can be invited on the same day.
And so you want an
algorithm that is
going to give you a schedule.
And, obviously, the schedule
is not necessarily unique.
I mean, if you had a bunch of
happy-go-lucky low overhead
friends, you know, they
all like each other
and you could just randomly
break them up into two groups.
You can think of
it as a partition.
A partition is a
grouping where--
then you have anything in a
set of nodes, for example,
and you partition it,
you're essentially
saying you're breaking
it up into two groups,
such that each node
is in exactly one
group, and each node--
and then we have
another property
associated with
the partition that
corresponds to the edges
between these nodes.
But we'll get to that in just--
just a minute.
Yeah, go ahead, Fadi.
AUDIENCE: How are we going
to deal with the-- with FGH,
because we only have
two parties and--
SRINI DEVADAS:
That's exactly right.
So-- so the purpose of this
puzzle is to determine whether
you can actually do this or
not, and so you are certainly
welcome to--
when you write a
computer program--
or when we write a computer
program here, it might say,
no can do, you know, find
a different set of friends
or maybe identify
a problem case.
You know, there's one
person who dislikes
all of your other friends.
Maybe you should drop
that person, right?
And so you can imagine that--
that you would
not necessarily be
able to satisfy these two
constraints for all graphs,
right?
And so that's really the
essence of the puzzle.
For what kind of graphs?
And this, it turns out that a
fairly famous kind of graph,
does--
does this puzzle have
a solution, right?
And so you-- you
have to look at this
and you kind of go, and
the first thing that
occurred to you was, hey, if I
had F, G, and H, if I invite F
on Friday, I have to
invite G and H on Saturday.
But then G and H don't
like each other, right?
So that's a problem, right?
And so in this
particular case, you've
identified this cycle that
indicates that this problem is
not solvable.
But, let's say, that
somehow you've placated G
and you patch--
they're patched up.
All right.
So-- so you end up having a
fairly complex graph structure
that looks like this, right?
And now what happens?
Now, is there-- is there a
solution to this problem,
to this particular puzzle?
I mean, A can come on any day
so let's ignore A. All right.
A is easy.
Suppose you invite-- you
can try and figure this out
by saying let's go ahead
and invite B on Friday.
So what does that imply?
That immediately implies that?
C is on Saturday, right?
What does that imply?
D is on Friday, right?
So you see-- you see
how this is going to go.
What does that imply?
E and F are on--
are on Saturday.
So I have E and F
on Saturday, OK?
And then what does that imply?
That F being on Saturday
implies that G, H, and I
have to be on Friday, right?
And then I-- don't forget
A. So let's just stick
A in here to even things out.
All right.
So-- so we kind of
did an algorithm here,
we executed an algorithm, right?
And it turns out that graphs
that can be partitioned
in this manner are--
I have a special name.
They're called bipartite graphs.
Bipartite graphs.
I'll write it out.
And that-- the reason they're
called bipartite graphs
is if you have a
bipartite graph,
you can always draw
it in this fashion.
Where you have A,
C, E, F, and then
you have B, D, G, H, I, such
that you never see edges
like this or like that.
All the edges go
from left to right--
or right to left.
They're undirected.
OK.
So that's really
a bipartite graph.
And if I draw this out--
oop, don't need that.
C goes to B and
D. A goes nowhere.
E goes to D. And F goes to
a bunch of different places.
Yeah.
So you're allowed to have--
this will still be a bipartite--
I won't-- this is not
the graph that we had,
but it's not that--
the edges can be crossing edges.
OK.
They just all have to
go from left to right.
You just can't have an
edge between A and C,
or C and A. You can't
have an edge between D
and H, et cetera.
All right.
So you want to-- you have
to be able to separate out
the nodes such that there are
no edges in this set of nodes,
and no edges between
this set of nodes,
that set of nodes.
And this is just a
topological property
that corresponds to
bipartite graphs.
And there's another
property that essentially
is equivalent to our
puzzle, which says,
bipartite graphs
are two colorable.
And it's obvious
as to why a bipar--
bipartite graph
is two colorable,
and what does it mean
to be two colorable.
Well, you need to
color each node
with two colors, in this case,
Friday and Saturday, such
that no pair of nodes
with an edge between them
have the same color.
So exactly equivalent to
what we've talked about here.
So our goal now is to discover
whether a bipartite graph--
or a given graph, excuse me--
is bipartite or not.
Once you know that a
graph is bipartite,
you know it's two
colorable, you know
it's a solution to our
problem, to our puzzle problem.
OK.
And, of course, in order
to do this, and if you
had a graph with--
you had thousands of friends
and, perhaps, tens of thousands
of edges, and you need to
discover it's not your dinner
problem, maybe.
But you need to discover whether
the graph is two colorable
or not, then you need to write
a computer program for this.
You need a graph representation.
You need to do this traversal,
et cetera, et cetera.
Go ahead, Josh.
AUDIENCE: If a graph
is two colorable,
is it always bipartite?
SRINI DEVADAS: Yes.
They're equivalent definitions.
Absolutely right.
Because what would happen
is if you can color it,
then it means that you can take
all of the red colors, you--
red could be equivalent
to Friday, and--
and then blue could be
equivalent to Saturday,
and all of the red colors could
be placed on the left, and--
and the blue on the right.
Fadi.
AUDIENCE: But then a graph
with no edges is one colorable
but also, by definition,
considered bipartite?
SRINI DEVADAS: Yes.
That's it.
That-- there's always
pathological cases,
and they're usually things
that get swept under the rug.
But one colorable is--
it is considered two colorable.
You can color it the two colors,
that's really what it is.
Let's talk about cycles to
get a sense for this property.
So immediately I
think you recognize
that when you have
something like,
I forget what it was
exactly, FGI or FGH,
whatever, that if you
had a cycle like this,
that a graph is not
bipartite, right?
A three cycle is not bipartite.
Is any cycle a problem?
If I have a cycle
in the graph, which
means that I can go from one
node back to the same node
through a sequence of edges and,
obviously, traversing nodes,
do I have a problem?
Is that can be immediately
declared that the graph is not
bipartite?
Yeah.
Go ahead, Julia, why not?
AUDIENCE: Well, like an
even cycle if it was,
for example, A, B, C & D--
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah, beautiful.
That's exactly what
I wanted to bring up.
So if I had something
like A, B, C, D, right?
That's clearly a cyclic graph,
and I could put on A and C
on here, and B and D up
here, and clearly there's
no edge between A and C,
there's no edge between B and D.
There's an edge between
A and B, there's
an edge between C and
D, and there's also
an edge between A and D and
C and B. So as I mentioned,
you're allowed crossing edges.
They all have to go from
left to right or right
to left, whichever way
you're looking at it.
So interestingly enough, I
mean, this is two colorable.
But when you get to--
when you get to odd cycles--
so I'll draw one out here--
in the middle, and let's say
I want to mark these nodes--
--the names, but let's say
that you have a five cycle now.
All right.
If you have a five
cycle, think about it.
You-- you are going to
go-- color this red.
So let me just go
ahead and say this
is red, which means
this needs to be blue,
that needs to be blue.
This blue implies this needs
to be red, which now implies
that this needs to be blue.
And it's like, whoops,
that's a problem, right?
So, interestingly
enough, the odd evenness
of the parity of
a cycle determines
whether a graph is
bipartite or not,
it doesn't mean that a graph
that only has four cycles in it
is necessarily
bipartite, because there
could be other reasons
for it not to be--
not to be bipartite.
Because you don't know about
the other cycles in the graph.
I mean, they could be--
you say it's only
up to four cycles.
Well, there could be
a three cycle in it,
and things get pretty
complicated when
you have things like that.
There's a lot of cycles in here.
This is a cycle like that,
there's a cycle like this,
and the moment you
put an edge in here,
now you're saying this goes
over here, goes like this.
There's a three cycle here.
But even if this
didn't exist, there
would be a five cycle,
et cetera, et cetera.
So there's a lot of
cycles and graphs, right?
And your algorithm,
essentially, needs
to ensure that for-- that
every cycle is an even cycle.
OK.
And that is exactly equivalent
to coloring it with two colors.
OK.
So we, obviously, need to
have a way of stopping here
in the sense that
when you have a cycle,
you are going to come back
and the cycle may be fine
because it's an even cycle.
But you, obviously, can't
keep going around the cycle
without terminating
in a computer program.
So we're going to have
to do a recursive search.
Which has interesting
termination conditions,
you know, as opposed
to the divide
and conquer, or even the
iterative enumeration
that we did where it was pretty
clear what the termination
condition was.
That the base case was
fairly straightforward
because you came down
to a list of length 1,
or you had something where you
broke things up to the point
where you had really
small problems
and that corresponded to
your base case, right?
But cycle detection,
especially when
you're doing
recursive traversal,
can be pretty tricky.
And we also, of course,
as I said initially,
we have to be able to
represent this graph structure.
Right.
I mean, you could
represent it as a matrix.
Right.
This-- or you could say,
well, I hate dictionaries,
I love lists, and that's
all I'm going to use
for the rest of my life, right?
Not a good idea.
But if you did that,
you could certainly
represent the graphs as a
matrix or two dimensional list.
It's called an adjacency
matrix representation--
and I won't write it out--
but, effectively, your rows
are all the nodes, and your
columns are all the nodes.
And you have a 1 or a zero
in the appropriate location
based on whether there's
an edge between the row
node and the column node.
And you can certainly do that.
And it's-- for most
cases-- in most cases,
it's a painful
representation to deal with.
Graphs are much easier
to deal with, especially
when you want to do traversal.
So we'll stick with
a graph structure.
All right.
So let's talk algorithms.
I want to take a slightly
different example.
It's similar to what
we have here, but--
and I want to talk about exactly
how an algorithm would work.
And we kind of did that.
So, actually, let's
run it on this one,
and then I'll write out what
the pseudocode for the algorithm
would be.
I'm going to ignore A here.
You can imagine that this
particular algorithm would
be run on this degenerate
case that corresponds to A,
and you'd end up coloring
this red or blue.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and color this red.
And I'm not done
with my problem,
but I'm done with the
particular graph that
corresponds to A,
because A can't reach
any other node in the graph.
So you ought to be a
little bit careful.
And the code I'm
going to show you
would need to be generalized
to take into account
this forest of graphs.
OK.
Because there's really a
bunch of different graphs
that are disconnected that are
part of the overall problem.
But if I start with B,
then I get connectivity
to all of the remaining
edges, and so I'm good there.
So let me go ahead
and color this red.
And so the way we
described it, we say,
I'm going to look for
the neighbors of B.
And so B is connected
to just C in this case.
And when I traverse
an edge, what do
I do with respect to the color?
I flip the color.
Right.
I change the color.
There's only two
colors so I can think
of it as flipping the color.
So I go and I traverse an edge.
I need to flip the color to--
to blue, right?
And then I get to C,
and when I get to C,
I then start traversing edges.
But when I traverse an edge,
I need to flip the color.
So this goes to R.
In the case of D,
I can go to two
different places,
and so I need to go
ahead and traverse to E.
And just for the
heck of it, I'm going
to add another edge there.
Right.
Because now you're
going to see how--
the code is going to get
a little more complicated
with respect to the
termination condition
that I described to
you, and the checks
that we need to perform
with respect to the fact
that we wanted this graph
to be two colorable.
OK.
So when I-- the way-- the way
this code is going to work
is I'm going to get to D,
and with that color red,
and I'm going to now see
for the first time-- this
is an interesting case.
For the first time, I'm going
to see that D has two neighbors.
OK.
Now, I need to traverse
both of these edges that
correspond to these two
neighbors in sequence.
I'm going to pick
one and go with that.
And then I'm going to
pick the other one, right?
In general, there's two
strategies that you can follow.
And one of which is called depth
first search, and the other
is called breadth first search.
OK.
So I'm not going to-- you're
going to see effectively
a depth first algorithm.
And I'm happy to tell you
about breadth first in detail
off line, but I'll mention
what the difference is here
so you get a sense of
what the differences are.
And they're two fundamental
search techniques,
traversal techniques.
And the depth first technique
says I'm going to take D,
and I'm going to pick
one of its neighbors,
and I'm going to go ahead
and say that, effectively,
that that's the only
neighbor, and I'm
going to explore
everything that I
can get to from that neighbor.
And then once I'm all done
and there's some termination
condition that happens,
I'm going to come back
and I'm going to look at this
other neighbor corresponding
to F.
So-- so what would
happen here in depth
first search is the following.
D would go to E, and when
I go through an edge,
I need to flip the color.
Right.
So I get a B here.
At this point,
unlike what we did
early on when we did
this particular example,
or something similar, I--
what I did was
when I saw R here,
I colored F and E both blue.
That's effectively what I did.
Remember that?
Right?
But now I'm actually
doing something different.
Right.
This is a different
execution corresponding
to depth first search.
Right.
When I looked at
all of my neighbors,
including the F case, I remember
we had some color for this,
and then we immediately
took G, H and I
and we colored them, right?
That is breadth first search.
OK.
That is looking at taking
one step in all directions
that you can take
and, essentially, it's
a frontier based
approach where I'm
taking the frontier
of my neighbors
and pushing it outward
one step at a time, right?
Contrast that with
what we're doing here.
You are going to take this--
the neighbor E
corresponding to D,
and then you're not
going to go to F,
you're, in fact, going
to go ahead and pick one
of the neighbors of E, right.
And you might even have in your
representation E's neighbor
being D. Because, you
know, D has E as a neighbor
and so does E having--
has D as a neighbor.
But you'll say,
oh, look, look, I
don't need to go look at D
now in my depth first search,
because D's already
been colored.
Right.
So you check that.
And then you say, oh,
what has not been colored?
I has not been colored.
And when I traverse an edge,
I need to flip the color,
and I'm going to go
ahead and put R in here.
All right.
And it's not that you
even go back to F now
from D. You don't go
back to D at this point.
You now look at I and you do
another recursion corresponding
to I, and you say, OK,
what about I's neighbors.
Well, E may be first,
but you already
done with E. I'm
going to go ahead
and I'm going to get to
F. And you do the flip
and you get B over here, right?
You still don't go-- go
back to D. You look at F
and you say I'm going to now
look at the neighbors of F,
and maybe you get H. And you
say this is R. Then you go back
and, now, for the
first time, you're
going to look at exhausting
the neighbors of a node
that you've actually reached
and you've gone to one neighbor
for.
And so-- so at this point
you go and you make this R.
So now you come back
and you say, am--
have I exhausted F's neighbors?
Yes, in the sense that all--
the neighbors that
I needed to look at,
because they didn't have
colors, have been exhausted.
And, of course, F had
D and I as neighbors.
And they already had colors
so I'm cool with that, right?
I don't need to--
I don't need to touch them.
Now, at this point,
I'm popping up
because I've exhausted
F's neighbors.
I'm going to go back
to where I came from.
How did I get to F?
I did not get to F from D.
I actually got to F from I,
right?
So I'm going to go to I.
But the fact of the matter
is that I is done because I
didn't have to deal with E
and I've already--
I'm already done with that.
Then I go back to E,
same thing, right?
Then, finally, I get
back to D, and I say,
oh, now I need to go look
at F, and I go and I say,
oh, F is already colored
so, therefore, I'm done.
This is the simplest
representation
that I can think of for a graph
that's also very efficient.
So I've messed with
this graph quite a bit,
so I want to claim that that
dictionary representation that
says graph equals
open curly brackets,
and then eventually close curly
brackets, corresponds to that,
but it's kind of roughly
corresponds to that.
And I can certainly write
out any graph representation
in Python for any
topological representation
that you give me.
But if you look at
what's up there,
the important thing is
I want to show you--
or tell you about the
constituents of this graph.
So graph is a dictionary, OK.
A dictionary is a set
of key value pairs.
You represent sets in
Python using curly brackets.
Right.
And each of the key value
pairs is represented
using some key colon val.
And you see a set
of key value pairs,
because you see these
commas between them,
and so what you see
here is the key.
And the keys could be
strings, they could be tuples,
you can have many
possibilities for keys.
And the key comes first.
And in this case, the
key is the string B. OK.
And so that represents
the name of the node B,
and the value is usually a list.
And in this case,
you have a list
that has a single entry
in it because B only has
one edge that goes to C. Right.
And so a more interesting
case, as you can see up there,
is D. And D connects to C,
F and E. And so you see D--
see E and F. Right.
So that's exactly what
the point here is.
Right.
This algorithm would
run differently
if you had a representation
that was equivalent
from a topological
standpoint, because there's
no order in the topology.
But I chose C, E, F. I-- you
know, it got typed somewhere,
C, E, F, and so the
order of neighbors
is C followed by
E followed by F.
Now, that is if you took
this list of neighbors
and you went from 0, 1, 2, in
terms of indices of that list.
There's nothing that's stopping
you from going 2, 1, zero.
In which case, you
would go F, E, C. Right.
Or you could do some crazy,
random ordering for the list
itself.
Right.
But it's all entirely up to you.
It is deterministic.
It's entirely up to you.
But, now, you see how the order
of the values that corresponds
to these lists that give you
the neighbors for every node
affects the execution
of the algorithm.
Right.
Now, you do not want the
result of the algorithm
yes or no, this graph
is bipartite or not,
to be affected by the
order that you see there.
Right.
Because when I draw a
graph like this, I mean,
this graph is
effectively something
that doesn't have order.
You can't really say anything
about the order of G,
H and I in relation to
F. I mean, they're--
well, that one is to the
left of it, they're all--
two of them are at the bottom.
But that's not
what this is about.
And so, obviously, that graph,
regardless of whether I--
I drew it like this or I--
you know, I drew it like that,
should be bipartite.
Both of those graphs that I--
that correspond to H
and G with their names
flipped, are either
bipartite or not bipartite.
Right.
So you absolutely cannot have
the algorithm being affected
by the order in which you
see C, E, F or what have you.
That make sense?
So you can do a lot of
operations on dictionaries.
It's probably
something that you want
to look at by looking at
the code that we have here
and looking at the code from
graph analysis algorithms,
and I'm happy to point
you to other literature.
But the way you access
a dictionary is--
looks a lot like
accessing a list.
So you can say
something like graph A,
and you say something
like graph A,
if A is not a key in the graph,
it would give you an error.
But you can certainly
get values back,
and you can also assign values.
So graph A, B would give-- it
would give you this list C,
and you can go off and you can
say something like graph A,
B dot append--
--and you can say D. And if you
did that, if you did graph A,
B dot append D, then
that's effectively
taking this and adding D to it.
So you can mutate the
graph if you wanted.
We don't have to
do that in our code
for bipartite, graph
checking, because we are not
mutating the graph, we're
just traversing the graph.
But you could certainly do that.
So the dictionaries are a
pretty cool representation.
Encourage you to
learn about them.
And they're useful
in many instances.
Clearly, they replace lists
because you can certainly
have keys as integers, right?
You can also have
negative numbers as keys.
There's nothing that's
stopping you from doing that.
And you don't have to
represent the negative number
as a string.
I mean, you could just
have keys that are--
that go from minus 22
to 27, what have you.
So, hopefully, you
have some sense
of what this code is
going to look like.
Both from a standpoint
of the algorithm, which
we executed a few times,
and from the standpoint
of the structure, the
representation of the graph.
So let's take a look at
about 10 lines of code
that corresponds to
bipartite graph coloring.
So it fits on a screen.
OK.
And so this is a
pretty tight code.
It does exactly what
we want it to do
in the sense of it's going to
determine whether a graph is
bipartite or not.
And it has a bunch of arguments.
A graph is what you
imagine it to be.
It's the input graph.
We have to start from somewhere.
This graph has a list
of key value pairs.
The keys happen to be the nodes.
You should never depend
on the keys being
stored in a particular order.
There's ways of saying--
you know, you can say
things like graph dot keys.
And this is going to give
you back a list of keys.
And it's possible that
when you say graph dot
keys, at one point
in the program,
you get the keys in
a particular order.
And when you say it at a
different part of the program,
you get the keys in
a different order.
OK.
But all-- the keys won't change.
If there's no bugs
in your program,
you'll get the same
set of keys, but they
may be in different order.
So you obviously want to start
with some node in the graph,
and you're going to color
it with a particular color,
color it red.
I think I had shaded and hatched
here, so sha stands for shaded,
and hat stands for hatched.
But you can use what you want.
So if you see the invocation
here, bipartite graph color--
graph three starts with a node.
This is an-- its
coloring is a dictionary,
and so we are also
representing not only the graph
as a dictionary, but we're
also representing the mapping
that we get.
Namely, the node B
was colored with red.
So B is a key in this
coloring dictionary.
And R red is--
is the color that's a value.
Right.
So you can represent mappings.
Key values or mappings.
Right.
So the coloring of a node
is also a dictionary.
And so that's
essentially what we have.
So I'm going to start with--
none of the nodes are colored,
so that's why this is empty,
and I'm going to
start with A, and I'm
going to start with the color
shaded, which means that A
is going to be colored shaded.
Or A is going to be shaded.
OK.
And this is going to return
true or false depending
on whether the graph
is bipartite or not.
And if it's true,
then I'm going to get
something interesting with
respect to the mapping of nodes
to colors.
That's my dictionary coloring.
And, otherwise,
I get false back,
which an empty dictionary.
Because when I have something
that's false, I mean,
you could imagine saying, well,
there's a problem case here.
You can color all of
these different nodes,
but I'm kind of stuck here
because of that five cycle.
But that's kind of
indeterminate in terms
of what the colors need to be.
And so-- unless you were
actually going to go off
and mutate the graph
and remove a node and--
and say this is the friend
you want to dump today,
and then the rest of them are
going to be invited for dinner.
In that case, you
could obviously
return a coloring
dictionary, even
in this case of the graph--
original graph not
being bipartite.
But most of the time you're
probably in a situation
where if it's not bipartite,
you don't return anything other
than false.
All right.
So let's take a look at
what each of these things
do, and then you'll also get
a sense of how we manipulate
dictionary structures.
So I'm just going to explain
very quickly each line of code
here.
So this pair of lines of--
this pair of lines of code,
essentially, say
something like, well,
if you've given me
a starting node,
it's just a check on the input.
The starting node
is not in the graph,
it's not a key in
the graph, then
I'm throwing up my hands here.
This is not a graph.
It's not a bipartite graph.
I can give you a
coloring, right.
So easy check.
Not much there.
This is an interesting check.
This, essentially,
is going to check
to see whether the particular
node that you have,
this is going to be
done recursively.
So anytime you
arrive at a node, you
have to check whether there's
already a color there or not.
If there's no color, then you
move forward, and you color it,
and you also move
forward in the sense
that you'll probably go ahead
and if it has neighbors,
you will traverse the neighbors.
Right.
But if it has a color, if
it's already in coloring,
that means it
already has a color.
Right.
Because the keys that correspond
to the coloring dictionary
are exactly the same in the
sense that they're graph nodes
and they're also in
the graph dictionary.
Right.
The mappings are, of course,
completely different,
and the coloring dictionary
is being grown as we speak,
or as we execute.
But the graph dictionary
is actually not mutated.
It's static.
OK.
And so this check here says
that I'm going to go ahead,
and if it's not in
coloring, oh, that's great.
I'm going to go ahead and
whatever color I have,
I'm going to go ahead
and color it with that.
That's what coloring
start equals color does.
It just colors the node.
OK.
And then that effectively
is adding the key value pair
start comma color to
the coloring dictionary.
That's what it does.
Otherwise-- well, I
got two cases here.
Right.
This thing has already been
colored, but I have two cases.
I want to color it with
something different from what
it's already been colored.
That's a problem.
That's exactly when
we get a five cycle
and we throw up our hands.
So we're done here.
We just say doesn't matter
what we've colored so far,
it's all garbage.
You know, this thing can't be
colored with two colors given
the constraints I
have, so I'm just
going to return false
and an empty dictionary.
So anything that coloring
had in it, I mean, is gone.
Right.
Because it's bogus.
Otherwise, this
recursion would say,
oh, well, I'm going to return
true for this thing here,
and I'm going to--
it has been colored, which means
that, you know, I haven't--
I don't want to do
any more work on it.
I mean, I got this node here.
It's already-- it
was already colored
and was consistently colored.
So if I don't want to
get into infinite loops,
I better not, you know, start
traversing nodes from this node
because I've already
seen it before.
All right.
So the fact that it's
already colored correctly
is a termination condition.
This is important.
That says that I don't want
to keep repeating myself,
that is like going through
the cycle over and over.
Right.
If you didn't have that, right?
That make sense?
Yep.
That's important.
So, now-- well, this is a flip.
So there's no recursion,
there's no procedure calls here,
this is just flipping the color.
That make sense?
So, now, the last part, which
is the part where I'm actually
doing depth first search
is the part which says, OK,
I got to the point now
where I'm-- essentially,
haven't done any returns here.
Right.
I've colored this with color,
and I've flipped the color.
Right.
So these two lines are executed.
No returns.
These lines are executed.
And, now, I have clearly
already colored start
and I flipped the
color and I'm going
to go ahead and make the
recursive call corresponding
to the neighbors
of start, and all
I have to do to look at
the neighbors of start
is to return the
list corresponding
to the value of graph start.
Remember, I said,
graph A or graph start
is going to give you this--
this list, and I can go
ahead and append to it and--
I'm not going to mutate,
but I could have done that.
And so that is going
to give me my list
and I'm just going to
go through, enumerate
that list in whatever order that
it came to me, and start with--
I'm going to call
the first element
vertex, because that's also a
vertex or a node synonymous.
And I'm going to send in vertex
here, graph stays the same,
vertex is the same.
I've modified colorings, so
I want to pass that over.
And, obviously, I'm going
to pass new color here
because I've done the flip.
Right.
And if I ever--
I get something
that's false, that
means I've found an odd
cycle and I return false.
And then if
everything works out,
I return true in the coloring.
OK.
So if I go ahead and run that,
if my machine hasn't gone
to sleep, doesn't do very much.
You know, the first graph,
it was not colorable.
You can check these
results by yourself.
But this is more--
the reason I'm
putting this up is
to give you a sense of what the
coloring dictionary looks like.
It's just so you get some
more exposure to these things.
So in this case you get a
non-empty coloring dictionary
for the second run.
So I ran it four times
on four different graphs.
You get a non-empty
coloring dictionary.
It's true.
The graph is bipartite.
And notice that the order in
which this coloring dictionary
was--
what was created was
certainly a function
of the execution
of the algorithm.
But this order might
actually change
if I keep running
this algorithm,
and if my machine had different
loads, and so on and so forth.
But you would always get through
for any graph representation
that is bipartite
or too colorable.
But you have no control over
whether F hat comes first,
or E hat comes first.
Those could be flipped.
All right.
So never depend on the order
of keys in a dictionary.
OK.
But, certainly, the
existence of keys
in a dictionary you can-- or the
nonexistence you can depend on.
All right.
Good.
So that's really
all I had to say.
Any questions?
All right.
Excellent.
I want credit for
finishing one minute early.